hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and in this video
i will be breaking down just how strong
aaron's new founding titan form really
is and i will be looking at what it
would actually take to defeat this
gigantic titan at full power if he were
determined to completely destroy the
world this is a video that many of you
guys have been requesting especially
with the final season of the anime
finally revealing this insane titan form
so let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our attack on titan
videos and you want to see more in the
future just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with that youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications please be advised that
this video will contain attack on titan
manga spoilers i will be looking at how
strong aaron's founding titan form is
based on all of the information
available in the manga so please proceed
with caution you have been warned now
back when aaron's gigantic founding
titan form was just revealed in the
manga i made a video speculating about
how strong this titan would be and
recently i made a video that talked
about all of erin's different titan
forms and powers throughout the course
of the entire series however i never
made an entire video talking about how
strong aaron's founding titan is after
all of the information about it was
revealed in the manga now that the
series has ended and we have all the
necessary information and now that this
form has been revealed in the anime i
thought that this would be the perfect
time to dedicate a full video to this
titan's unbelievable power aaron's
founding titan is an absolutely massive
creature that is some sort of weird
mixture between a skeletal dinosaur and
a spider i honestly don't know how to
even describe it and it's never made
clear how this thing even functions in
terms of biology and physics what we do
know is that this thing is by far the
biggest titan that we've ever seen in
the history of attack on titan and even
amir fritz's own founding titan which
had all nine titan powers in one body
didn't come close to the size of aaron's
founder unfortunately an exact
measurement has never been given for the
height of aaron's founding titan and the
panels are not always consistent so his
size seems to vary depending on which
panel you look at but by comparing this
gigantic titan to the wall titans were
roughly 50 meters tall it appears that
the height of eren's titan reaches
upwards of 500 meters that is my
personal estimate even though as i said
depending on which panel you look at it
seems to vary i've seen estimates online
ranging from 350 meters all the way up
to 900 meters but i think that 500 is
closer to the actual number if you're
interested in titan size comparisons in
particular i made an entire video
ranking every titan from smallest to
largest so if you want to check that out
i will link it in the description now
speaking of aaron's titan size it goes
without saying that such a massive size
comes with incredible raw physical power
even without the wall titans aaron's
founding titan has the ability to crush
virtually anything in its path and with
the rumbling he is able to level entire
cities in a matter of minutes initially
i thought that this titan's immense size
would make him slow and that speed might
be the one big weakness that his
opponents could exploit nevertheless
according to hanji aaron's titan and the
wall titans need only about four days to
destroy the entire massive continent
that marlei is located on which means
that they definitely move very fast and
you might think that even though aaron's
titan can move relatively quickly from
one location to another maybe his
reaction time is slow like maybe if you
can climb on top of him you'll be able
to run circles around him because his
strange gigantic body simply can't react
fast enough to a potential attacker who
has managed to actually climb on top of
him and is not just waiting on the
ground to be stomped but even attack
from above is largely ineffective when
aaron made his deal with amir fritz he
unlocked the full potential of the
founding titan power something that not
even the former founding titan holders
could unlock before aaron makes a deal
with emir she is just a mindless slave
who carries out commands made by members
of the royal bloodline but after amir
makes her deal with aaron she does a lot
more than just blindly follow his orders
she actively helps him using the
terrifying full potential of the
founding titan the first to attempt an
aerial attack on aaron's titan is a
marlene airship squadron and this
happens in chapter 134.
they fly high enough over to titan that
aaron can't directly reach them and then
they drop hundreds of barrels filled
with explosives right on top of aaron's
titan and the wall titans however
because titans have the ability to
regenerate their bodies these low-level
explosives don't really have any real
effect on aaron's titan what's more
aaron's titan is then able to summon
zeke's beast titan on top of its back
and the beast titan hurls rocks up at
the airships which completely destroys
the entire squadron it is important to
note that at this point zeke is not the
one in control of the beast titan it is
being controlled by aaron and emir
this incident demonstrates just how
ineffective airships are against aaron's
titan despite the fact that they are
able to fly above him and attack him
from above oh and the ability to
manifest zeke's beast titan and control
it is only the beginning once the scout
warrior alliance uses an airplane to
land several titan shifters and
ackerman's on aaron's titan's back it is
revealed that aaron and emir have the
ability to summon a seemingly infinite
number of the former titan shifters that
had existed for over 2000 years in the
past these former shifters will appear
on aaron's titan's back just like zeke's
beast titan and they will also be under
aaron and emir's complete control armin
believes that these titans are being
directly controlled by emir herself
rather than aaron but in the end it
amounts to the same thing because aaron
and emir seem to share the same goal and
emir is using her powers to actively
defend aaron's founding titan form this
means that all of the former beast
titans warhammer titans jaw titans armor
titans and so on are at aaron's disposal
and none of them seem to have a will of
their own their actions don't reflect
the wishes of their actual titan holders
they are just mindless soldiers fighting
for aaron and emir that is why we even
see porco's jaw titan bertolt's colossal
titan and lara tiber's warhammer titan
fighting against reiner and the allies
and on behalf of aaron despite the fact
that while they were still alive poor
koberto de lara would never have done
that needless to say with all of those
former titans protecting aaron speed is
not really an issue many of the former
jaw titans are bound to be extremely
fast so even an enemy who can climb on
top of aaron and make his way past the
zeke's beast titan will have an
impossible task ahead of them the former
warhammer titans also possess longer
range weapons like bows and arrows which
makes it even easier for them to defend
aaron now in chapter 136
zeke was able to awaken the former titan
shifters who had a direct connection to
the people involved in the final battle
and then their titans turned against
aaron and helped the scout warrior
alliance this includes bertolt's titan
porcos titan grisha's titans xavers
titan and so on but this seems to have
only worked because these particular
shifters had a personal attachment to
the people involved in the battle
whereas the hundreds of other former
shifters from history did not so even
after zeke manages to turn a few of the
shifters against aaron there are still
many more shifters from the past who are
still fighting on aaron's side we also
have to consider the possibility that
aaron and emir could have stopped the
former shifters who were awakened by
zeke at any moment since emir was the
one who allowed them to manifest on
erin's back in the first place she
probably also had the power to make them
disappear at any time but she chose not
to because aaron did not want to
interfere with the freedom of the scout
warrior alliance if he had wanted to
interfere with their freedom aaron could
have just taken away their ability to
use titan powers from the start and then
there would have been no way to defeat
him in the first place in sum aaron's
founding titan has simply unbelievable
physical power this includes enormous
size and destructive potential legions
of wall titans at his disposal and every
former titan shifter throughout history
and all of their powers are at his
disposal as well but even all of those
physical powers don't tell the full
story of just how strong aaron's
founding titan form is and that is
because thanks to the paths aaron also
has a number of other non-physical
powers and abilities that he can
exercise over all the subjects of emir
as soon as aaron first initiated the
rumbling we witnessed his ability to
communicate telepathically with every
alden or subject of emir anywhere in the
world at any time whether a subject of
emir was on parodies island or somewhere
far away on the continent they could all
hear what aaron was saying despite being
a minority bloodline the ackermans were
also able to hear aaron's communication
at the same time people who are not
subjects of emir did not hear aaron and
while this telepathic radio free elder
ability is pretty cool it is nothing in
comparison to all the other things that
the founding titan can do the founding
titan can alter the very biology of
every single subject of emir in the past
one of the founding titan holders was
able to change the bodies of ldn's to
make them more resistant to a certain
disease zeke of course wanted to use
this founding titan ability to make all
ldn sterile and the founder can even
take away the power of the titans from
all the subjects of emir as we see later
again this means that if he had wanted
to aaron could have easily stopped
reiner peak armin annie and falco from
using their titan shifter abilities to
try and stop him he simply chose not to
take away their ability to transform
into titans because he did not want to
take away their freedom aaron also
demonstrated the ability to detach
himself from his gigantic founding titan
form and create a colossal titan that he
can then control this titan is roughly
the size of armin's colossal titan but
aaron's colossal titan has the
additional ability to harden parts of
its body such as his fists which is the
same ability that he possessed in his
attack titan form after consuming the
armor serum there has been some
speculation about whether aaron still
possessed the founding titan power after
being detached from the main founding
titan body because after zeke's death
and after aaron is detached from the
huge founding titan he also became
detached from that shining centipede
creature that is the source of all titan
powers and of course because of zeke's
death he no longer had a direct
connection to someone with royal blood
personally i believe that aaron did
still have access to the founder at this
time because emir was still on his side
after all aaron did not possess the
colossal titan shifter power and yet he
was able to take the form of a colossal
titan i believe that this is only
possible because aaron still had access
to the power of the founding titan
thanks to kimir and this brings me to
the most important point
make no mistake no power or force in the
world of attack on titan at the time of
the rumbling could have ever stopped
aaron's founding titan form if he was
fully committed to destroying the world
i've seen some people try to argue that
aside from allowing the alliance to keep
using their titan powers aaron was fully
prepared to go through with destroying
the world and mikasa just happened to
get him before he could finish the job
but we have to remember that even
without the founding titan power aaron
possesses the warhammer titan power and
he could have easily encased his main
body or what was left of it inside the
crystal that lara tiber had used if
aaron had done that mikasa would have
had no chance of killing him with her
blade so no if he didn't want to be
stopped nothing and no one could have
defeated aaron at full power in the
world of attack on titan he clearly
allowed himself to be stopped meaning
that he did not go all out but what
would it take to defeat aaron's titan
and bring the rumbling to an end if
aaron had been determined to destroy the
world at all costs marley had the right
idea when they tried to drop explosives
from above but because titan bodies can
regenerate they would need to have much
much more powerful explosives and of
course because aaron's titan can use
zeke's beast titan to shoot down the
airships they would need either
long-range missiles or airplanes that
fly much higher than airships can if we
look at our own world aaron could
theoretically be stopped with technology
that becomes available in the atomic age
which begins in the mid-40s and
continues into the 50s and beyond in
order to stop aaron you need the
explosive power of nuclear weapons and
long-range delivery systems for those
weapons you would also likely need
multiple nuclear weapons in order to
account for the fact that titans can
regenerate and so unless your explosion
hits aaron's main body right on target
the first time around he will just keep
regenerating and you will have to keep
trying armand even used the colossal
titans massive explosion on aaron's
founding titan and he still failed to
kill aaron so there is no guarantee that
even a nuke could take him out in one
try so to defeat aaron's founding titan
you need immense explosive power on the
level of nuclear weapons long range
delivery systems that have a high level
of precision and you likely need more
than one nuclear weapon especially if
you take the wall titans into account on
top of that we have to remember that
aaron's titan is a moving target so even
the early nuclear weapon delivery
systems like the gravity bombs used in
world war ii may have been far too
inaccurate to do the job sure they could
hit a city but a city was not a moving
target surrounded by gigantic clouds of
dust on all sides in addition nuclear
weapons were still extremely rare in the
40s so a truly reliable way to defeat
aaron's founding titan doesn't appear
until the 50s and 60s in our own world
in that era nuclear weapons technology
improved drastically more powerful bombs
were invented and more advanced delivery
systems were developed as well therefore
major nuclear powers from the cold war
era like the us and the soviet union
would have been able to take down a
threat of aaron's caliber but before
that era aaron's founding titan would
likely have destroyed everyone on earth
in the world of attack on titan even the
most advanced technology seems several
decades behind the atomic era so that
means that no one stood a chance against
aaron in that world if he had really
wanted to go all out and destroy
everything
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you're looking for something to watch
next check out our massive and growing
attack on titan video playlist link in
the description and in the pinned
comment feel free to share your thoughts
on how strong eren's founding titan form
is down in the comments below is there
anything that i missed is there
something that you disagree with no hard
feelings by all means feel free to share
your honest feedback down below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more attack on titan content in the
future just leave a quick like it only
takes a second but it helps a lot and of
course if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord to ego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma ingrata algital pate heffa
the red-haired fox hinokami and water
the toasted chi corey mcgowan spidey
left tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
and jeremy cummings finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews alicia octor bonnie
parks joy and garcia fat boy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy
phillips and alivania if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you